there could be complexity is just having
that many uh just another topic so
complexity is associated with having so
many satellites
uh especially with competing companies
and competing Nations do you see that as
an issue having tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of satellites yeah
it becomes a very interesting robotics
collision avoidance problem the the one
thing to keep in mind is perspective
like I know 10 000 satellites and twenty
thousand a hundred thousand satellites
sounds insane and it sounds really scary
but I mean just even look at how many
planes are in the air at any given time
and the planes are are bigger they're
flying slower which actually means
there's a greater chance of collision if
you think about you know two objects
occupying space if they're one's moving
really fast like imagine trying to you
know throw two basketballs at each other
relatively easy now try shooting two
bullets at each other and having like
you know at 90 degrees from each other
you have to have your timing down like
really perfect to do that now take that
times 10 you know and these objects are
taking up a physical space very small
amount of time they're relatively small
like most satellites are not very big
and they have ins Limitless altitudes to
deal with so even though you can have
what look like convergences you know
they can be 10 20 50 100 kilometers
difference often and you know they're
dealing with this like all the the all
space assets know hey I'm at this
orbital plane and this blah blah blah
and they know their altitudes and know
their safe distances and have these
margins built in and it's space so
there's like an insane amount of room
you know so there's there's a lot of
margin there's a lot of margin but of
course you can't excuse that all the way
like you have to still have plans and
and be considering that and considering
collisions and considering all of the
above